[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
weekly libertarian podcast that was
combining top secret documents with
Corvettes decades before it occurred to
Sleepy Joe Biden I am Matt Welch joined
by Nicole Espy Peter suderman and
Catherine mangu Ward happy post MLK Day
gang howdy Matt hello happy Tuesday
since last week convened it has been
announced that President Joseph Robbins
Biden II has been caught not once not
twice but three times so far admittedly
by his own team uh possessing classified
documents occasionally even top secret
ones the first at his previously little
known Washington Think Tank discovered
by his own lawyers and reported to the
National Archives last November is that
the uh no Malarkey
that's setting a good tone right now for
this podcast yes a bus based Think Tank
uh that was caught on November 2nd and
revealed by the White House January 9th
mind the gap the second was in the
garage of his Wilmington Delaware house
discovered and reported on December 20th
and revealed publicly January 12th and
the third in a room next to the garage
was found last Wednesday revealed on
Thursday attorney general Merrick
Garland appointed a special counsel that
Thursday uh to investigate how the
documents got there
and if there are any prosecutable
implications you may recall that Garland
had previously appointed a special
counsel to look into the classified
documents handling of Biden's
predecessor Donald Trump yeah Catherine
uh Libertarians tend to dislike uh or at
least distrust over classification and
presidents and the FBI and just Merit
Garland uh so what are Libertarians to
make of this unfolding legal drama
I think as usual Libertarians are to
make that they were right all along this
is uh this is such a shock coming for me
at the top of the reason podcast I know
but the sort of deep deep desire to make
political hay out of this is making both
the coverage stupid and the remedy
stupider so I actually this morning went
and just read like the most Normy stuff
I could find about this because I
realized I was getting most of my
information on this from Twitter and you
know whatever else sources have kind of
dumped it in my life
from my bubble because my bubble
contains this Scandal but I don't care
so um I was not seeking out information
I went and read NPR's coverage I read
the New York Times coverage
every single one of the pieces is like
what
I mean is this really the same as the
Trump stuff it seems I mean Donald Trump
though he's bad and Biden is good so in
that sense these seem different like
it's really embarrassing the tone of the
coverage I think
um you know I actually do think it is
different in in some important ways but
it is it is the same in this crucial way
which is as you said math the
libertarian point the reason these guys
don't know that they randomly have
classified documents in their garages or
locked closets or whatever is because
too much stuff is classified because
presidents are dealing casually in this
information all the time
and because presidents are narcissistic
[ __ ] who want to hold on to lots of
documentation for their like
presidential libraries and their Memoirs
and stuff and I think that that's at
least part of what's going on here too
the sort of doubling of records for
personal or partisan purposes which
results in violating these rules
I don't think the nation is in danger
from any of this and so in that sense I
think we're making too big a deal out of
it like this is the roof skis aren't
going to get their hands on this and
even if they did there's nothing in them
as far as we know that's really really
actually super nuclear football
come on just say it occasionally and
it'll freak people nuclear football the
codes yeah uh Peter is there anything
weird about the timeline here
um that I over focused on in the little
intro bits uh takes the White House more
than two months to publicly acknowledge
the first discovery and then when they
do so they don't mention the second one
whoops until a few days later when
people start to report more uh uh out
about it uh or am I in my own filter
bubble oh I don't know I don't think
it's at all weird when you know the
sitting president and his staff uh kind
of failed to report doing the exact same
thing that they strongly suggested that
their predecessor might be locked up for
that seems pretty normal to me yeah what
are you talking about yeah okay
bear it up this should have been coming
out swinging uh spicy I assuming that's
fine uh and uncharacterically brief nick
uh have uh I I uh have you seen uh as
many Republicans pouncing in subheads
since fill in the blank Nick Gillespie
joke they yeah they have been pouncing
like nobody's business but uh you know I
also am kind of annoyed that nobody
pointed out that like Joe Biden has like
20 cars I mean he's like second to Jay
Leno and Jerry Seinfeld and you know
uh kind of duplicative automobiles none
of which get more than five miles a
gallon I think that should be the focus
for Eric Clapton as we learned this
weekend from uh Dave's car ID service oh
yeah well and you know of course Jeff
Beck major Gearhead Matt Welch can we
can we stop talking about uh ancient
politicians the old ones and talk talk
about classic rock stars who are
recently yes
uh yeah um I don't have much to add to
what uh Catherine and Peter said but uh
the one thing I was thinking about as
this story came out
um this uh topic that was a focus of
concern not just for reason Libertarians
but for a lot of people particularly
people on the Progressive left in the
early years of guat of the global war on
terror
um which was the over classification of
government documents particularly at the
federal level and I dug up there was a
study uh from the early uh like around
2006 2007 that said like fully a third
of documents that are put into some
category of you know classification like
of high classification so that they
can't just be publicly released
immediately a third of those shouldn't
have been done
um and uh the uh the government agency
that actually uh looks over all of this
the information secure 30 oversight
office in its 2021 annual address to the
to the president's office actually said
you know what like particularly because
of covid there's a huge problem with a
you know a spike in stuff that's both
classified in a backlog and getting the
stuff out so uh if this brouhaha is
going to do something other than just
kind of you know throw a few more fuel
pellets on a kind of tribal political
polarization Fires for God's sake uh you
know let us revisit the idea of why are
so many documents being classified in
the first place uh we're supposed to
live in an open society and a free
society and a transparent one so for
[ __ ] sake let us see more of the JFK
assassination uh reports I think it's a
long last I think it was Martin Luther
King who said a republic if you can get
your federal document retention
procedures right
yeah now then we wouldn't judge his we
wouldn't judge his sculpture truly
inspirational yeah uh Catherine uh
before we leave the topic what's a good
way going forward to judge whether uh
any of this stuff is of actual concern
to people who are not necessarily uh
trying to score a political fight and
and uh what does that have to do with
Hunter Biden's nudity
right I mean this is this is the thing
right we the battle that we are having
right now in all of our politics is who
gets to control what information other
people are allowed to see maybe that's
the Battle of all politics I don't mean
to get existential about it here but
that could be what politics has always
been about and it's just more text than
subtext these days but
we are we're like retaining this last
little delusion from an earlier era that
maybe Secrets can be kept and that the
public can be prevented from knowing
things now of course the public often
doesn't know things because people don't
care or are lazy or stupid or not
interested that's fine but I think in
general our bias both in terms of say I
don't know social media misinformation
policies and also probably
classification documents is that the
the the bar should just be very very
high for for really truly throwing up a
wall in which we prevent people from
knowing things do we need to casually
announce the exact position of U.S
troops in the time of war no probably
not we could keep that one on the down
low almost everything else yeah people
should probably know what's going on for
crying out loud yeah and just to throw
some more on the social media thing uh
the ongoing Twitter files which are kind
of been possible to keep up with on some
level and they tend to uh bore and I'm
not sure I need to read a lot more Alex
Berenson uh in in life but uh over and
over again they come around to
politicians and other institutions
nagging negging uh social media
companies can you please suppress this
person can you support please suppress
that person these These are elected
officials in many cases
um asking uh to suppress opinion that's
awful that's just awful and that
instinct is awful and all of you people
you're all awful okay moving on last
week was a was was that an Adam Schiff
in person I know but it might have been
uh um you know sometimes we work on a
subconscious level and it just you know
flows out I think that was reading Nick
Cave and he was explaining how the
process works uh moving on last week was
a busy one
speaking of various culture wars of our
ongoing culture and policy Wars over
public education and wokeness and I use
that word because they're all using that
word uh the newly majoritarian House GOP
introduced the CRT transparency act and
CRT in this case does not stand for
critical race Theory it stands more like
against critical race Theory it stands
for uh curriculum review of teachings
transparency act they're doing it again
Nick they're doing it again uh sponsor
Scott Fitzgerald from Washington
Wisconsin Washington Wisconsin sure uh
this cyber Paradise explained quote it's
clear bureaucrats and teachers unions
Have No Reservations about putting
divisive material such as critical race
theory in front of our children that
seeks to put people in groups based on
skin color or gender the CRT
transparency act will solve this problem
by helping parents get a straight answer
about what their children are hearing in
school end quote other news in this
category of recent vintage includes
house Republican Jim Banks of Indiana
announced the creation of an anti-woke
caucus to push back on quote wokeness
tyranny unquote in governmental and
private institutions new Republican
governors in places like Iowa and
Arkansas have announced upon swearing in
some pretty bold school choice
aspirations while also in the case of
Arkansas governor Sarah Huckabee Sanders
signing an executive order Banning CRT
and the official use of the word latinx
in government documents Catherine um
there's a lot of micro stuff to respond
to here which is what we should normally
do and focus on the most but I want you
to give us a sense of a macro question
uh especially as we are wrapping up to
national school choice week right
um is in your estimation the school
Choice Movement which we tend to like
over here at reason
at this point inextricably linked to the
anti-woke movement which is producing a
more let's say mixed bag of policy
results from a Libertarian point of view
yeah that hurt that question hurts my
heart a little bit I
yeah thanks uh I would like sorry I
would like to think that it is not I
would like to think that um the the push
for school choice is decades old it is
it represents a very very real and
successful policy initiative that came
just out of Milton Friedman's brain
basically and into the world
um the fact that in the last couple of
years it has become entangled with these
you know extremely kind of high
temperature fights over race and gender
um I don't I don't think necessarily
spells the Doom of the school Choice
Movement as a concept but it's certainly
has confused the brand and I don't think
that's a coincidence to be clear like
the Republicans did this to themselves
for the most part but I got to imagine
that the teachers unions your Randy
weingartens and such are absolutely
delighted to see this smear that they
have tried to perpetuate for a long time
that somehow school choice is secret you
know conservatives being racist and
anti-gay
um now manifesting in the real world
that is is not a need not be what school
choice is about
and I hope that we can get back to the
real thing I will say though just to
kind of do the like high level analysis
here like bands on talking about and
teaching critical race Theory are not
pro-free speech
they're just not like the Republicans
that are out here saying I'm defending
Free Speech I'm defending free speech
and so I'm Banning certain speech it's
just really important to say again like
that's not how this works that's not how
any of this works and uh and I think
that it's sort of easy somehow for some
people to to gloss over that in this
debate I don't understand why but Peter
um on the Randy Weingarten side of the
the sin
sins in education I mean are not
teachers unions particularly in bluish
areas or deep blue areas
pursuing kind of some crazy Equity stuff
I mean there's news out I think it was
Virginia Maryland you guys will correct
me
um of uh uh School uh officials
suppressing National Merit Scholarship
Awards because though that's not good
for Equity or something like that
um there's some crap out there so is it
isn't it a good thing for the House GOP
to go out there and say hey look we want
transparency we're going to mandate
transparency uh uh I'm telling you you
can't receive federal funds unless you
show us everything that you're teaching
uh out there in the world
if you pronounce the letters CRT like a
word
like a word what do they sound like they
sort of sound like cart but like without
the a Kurt but this sounds kind of like
cart right and I think that what this
whole debate is doing is putting the
horse before the hurt
oh my God I hate you this is what long
weekends do that was just for Catherine
no I'm actually I'm actually serious
here which is what is happening is that
Republicans are assuming the Primacy of
public schools and then saying well they
have to they have to be transparent
about everything and then we're gonna
we're gonna inform parents and then
we're gonna have the debate after that
right when instead what we need to do is
say let's give parents a choice about
what kinds of schools and what kinds of
uh education their kids are going to
have up front and this is why school
choice works much better than arguing
about the curriculum in schools now once
we have public schools they exist we're
not going to not have public schools
this semester next year the next five
years that's the public schools are a
given and I think it's just completely
unrealistic to say oh we will just not
have public schools in some sort of near
future like foreseeable timeline once we
have that I don't think it's entire
entirely crazy to give people
information right like the the to let to
let parents know what they are being
taught and I certainly think there's a
lot of stuff that many parents would
find objectionable being taught in
public schools but I don't think that
arguing that trying to use Public
Schools as the locus of that debate is
gonna solve this problem instead it's
going to intensify the conflict and you
have folks you have folks like Jim Banks
from Indiana who in the House of
Representatives said he would be forming
a new caucus to take on wokeness and
like the whole thing just sounds like a
parody of Republican conservative
anti-woke uh you know politics right
like wokeness which presents his quote
the greatest domestic threat to America
today a tyranny that's changing America
through indoctrination right like this
is this is just wildly over hyped and
overblown and it's not it's not a good
it's not like a responsible approach to
solving these problems because a
responsible approach would say look
let's try and give people choice
wherever we can rather than fight over
what the one thing that every kid should
be taught actually is
I also want to say like if you want
transparency about what your kids are
being taught in the classroom and this
is as I'm creating two categories here
people who just want to be mad about it
and then actual parents of actual kids
in actual schools and if you want
transparency about what's going on in
the classroom
by far the best approach would be
to ask your kids teacher what they are
teaching your kid like I don't know why
the federal government needs to be
involved at all it it's just a mystery
like it's not a mystery it's a zero
percent mystery people want to be mad
about it but
it's not hard to find out what kids are
learning in school if you have kids
it's really not I I disagree with that
um I mean I I or let me I think it's
more complicated than that and you know
the one good thing in Ron DeSantis is uh
don't say gay laws was you know an
insistence on transparency for parents
or or actually for taxpayers it should
be because all of us whether we have
kids in school or not are paying for
this
um and in a lot of places that's not the
case I mean my uh both of my kids went
to uh public school in Ohio and it was
not always clear what teachers were
teaching and uh you know you try talking
to them there are oftentimes either
obfuscating or just not very good at
communication or so a federal Bill to
solve that Nick no no no no no that's
these are two totally separate things
right
um you know the idea that the federal
government is the place you know the one
place of redress for this is obviously
stupid and insane and it's funnier the
the gets funnier and funnier the more
hysterically reactionarily conservative
the Republicans who are calling for this
and somebody like Jim Banks who has also
sponsored legislation enshrining
qualified immunity in law rather than a
shitty Court decision
um you know who denies the federal
election you know who denies uh the
election of Joe Biden who went back and
forth on January investigating January 6
after Trump was like Hey I really don't
want it to be investigated I mean it's
great that small government
conservatives are the ones who are now
saying you know that this needs to be
you know you know legislated at the
federal level if not at the U.N that'll
be the next step right where they go for
we need one world government that stamps
out wokeness everywhere
um so there's a lot of [ __ ] about
that the The Way Forward particularly in
K-12 situations is school choice that's
not a mystery it's not a miracle and
it's exactly what should be happening
and the one one thing I would say
without going into vowel you know vowel
challenged jokes and things like that is
that uh transparency demanding
transparency on the local level and at
the state level or at the the district
level is really important and that
probably will help fuel school choice
support for school choice because the
more people know what's being taught and
what's not being taught and what values
are being transmitted through education
which they always are going to be I
think there will be more and more uh
backing by you know parents as well as
taxpayers to say you know what I'm not
going to support everything that's being
taught in every school but I'm much more
comfortable with the idea that kids and
parents get to choose among a lot of
competing curricula that will be very
different with very different focuses
and very different kind of moral
valances Catherine in potential defense
of Jim Banks and even reactionariness
neither which are uh categories that I
tend to defend but the purposes of
furthering the conversation uh one of
the things on Jim Banks's anti-woke
caucus to do list is to reverse
um President Biden's first day in office
or certainly first week first two days
in office
um uh executive order
um calling for a whole of government
sort of audit and an action upon judging
everything through an equity Focus to
determine whether the outcomes of X or Y
or Z public policy has a disparate
effect on different communities based on
their immutable characteristics and if
so doing something about that that like
didn't get a lot of press we wrote about
it a reason conservatives tend to write
about it too but in if there are places
and there are places
where the governing culture the media
culture the the culture that people
misnamed the cathedral where those are
just sort of dominant and do things that
no one really pays attention to because
it all seems like the temperature of the
water to the fish who were swimming in
it isn't it useful to have someone
saying look we need to reverse this
which is on his things to-do list like
we need to stop this accurate this
Equity executive order of course you
can't do that until you have
um you know dictator for Life Donald
Trump as the president
um but like you need someone who's
organized around a
um almost reactionary opposition to
these things that otherwise people don't
pay attention to but then insinuate
themselves in perpetuity in public
policy yeah I mean I I'm sympathetic to
that desire and I I don't think that
Biden's approaches the right one I guess
I think that you know it is it is
particularly reasonable to make these
things a priority when it is exclusively
about the conduct of government right
and I think that to me is the thing
that's the most troubling about the
structure of the world caucus and the
structure of so much of our fights about
wokeness is that um
it is perfectly is a perfectly
reasonable thing for members of Congress
to say to the president hey I'm not sure
that I agree with your goals and
guidelines for creating public policy
like that's how we should be doing the
creation of public policy
at the same time
um to just allide the distinction
between that
um say Twitter's moderation policies
hypothetically and then this thing in
between where Public Schools live right
I mean this is this is something that in
our banned books issue uh we wrote and
talked about a bunch Public School
curriculum setting is in many ways the
stickiest Wicket of of where
um where Free Speech starts and stops
and it is they are public institutions
they are mandatory attendance unless we
forget truancy laws still exist and
um and so and same with public libraries
uh you know there there is a difficult
question there about what Canon should
be taught I I appreciate Nick's focus on
transparency but I still think the thing
that matters more here is individual
responsibility I think that transparency
laws are far far far too often
ultimately used as cudgels I think that
the compliance costs of transparency
laws are sometimes weaponized and that
I'm not it's not clear to me that
transparency will be better for school
choice in the end if we end up requiring
everyone who wants to start a school to
date a dump every single thing about
that school just because one dollar of
government money goes into that school
that's that doesn't feel like a good and
glorious school choice future to me
and so I think that you know again the
place that I would say it's like if tax
you know taxpayers have a say but not
not that big of a say honestly what
matters I think is
the kids themselves the parents
themselves the teachers themselves and
the lower you can devolve that the
better certainly again the federal
government has absolutely no business
here um Peter you're from Florida
Catherine mentioned the governor Ron
DeSantis clearly has some a possible
presidential aspirations uh he recently
appointed uh to the board of a public
liberal art school called the new
College uh Chris Ruffo Christopher rufo
um as his byline would suggest uh who is
arguably the leading anti-crt meaning in
this case a critical race Theory uh
activist uh in the country
um just wondering if you can give us any
insight onto that transaction and what
it might uh tell us about DeSantis or
just on the state of uh applied
Republican anti-wokenness in education
it's mostly symbolic hippie punching
new college is the weird college in
Florida and it's it is it's a public
institution but it's the weird college
and like that's really the best way to
think about it it's not just artsy it's
out there it's sort of fringy it's where
they send the kids who like you don't
you kind of think they're maybe smart
but you don't really know what to do
with them and then they all go and do
you don't really know what for a bunch
of years there's no transparency there
and it's like self-consciously the weird
College it's also not very large and not
very influential relative to the to the
genuinely big schools in the Florida
public uh University system FSU
University of Florida
um and so to me the choice of of Locale
a venue here to make the move that
DeSantis made is really telling because
if DeSantis wanted to make a big change
in the public university system then he
would start with the big highly dominant
highly influential schools instead he
just went after the one that is known
for being kind of kind of silly and
absurd in certain ways but like that's
it's you know it's it's it's not it's
not an important School in the sense of
like they're setting the the woke agenda
for Florida or for the nation it's
important in the sense that everybody
knows that's where the weird lefties go
I just want to point out to uh great uh
alums of new College in uh Florida uh
one is uh one is uh Rick doblin the
founder of maps uh the uh the
Psychedelic research Group which is
pushing uh MDMA through FDA trials
should be online and fully legal uh MDMA
assisted therapy Psychotherapy within a
couple years and uh then also Bruce
barrettsford Redmond uh a uh MTV uh pimp
by ride reality TV producer who was
convicted of murder so that's what you
get this is what you get when you mess
with us experimental State College you
know with no grades and just let people
be
um
um can I uh just throw a little tidbit
in here which is that I was talking with
someone this weekend who is not who does
not pay attention to politics who is not
anywhere inside my bubble and
it it emerged yeah it emerged that she
had confused George Santos and Ron
DeSantis
and thought that all the George Santos
identity stuff was about
Ron DeSantis leading contender
to challenge Donald Trump for the
Republican nomination for president
and if that I don't know that just feels
like great to me like I love that people
are out there living a life where George
Santos and Ron DeSantis are functionally
the same person may we all I just wish
that they would combine them and I think
I've made this uh suggestion last week
that they combined them into Ron Santo
at Welch
the diabetic uh Hall of Fame third
baseman for the Chicago Cubs who really
did let's not let's not confuse people I
will add to that Captain that I once
thank God it never aired but uh uh I was
once interviewed by 60 Minutes by Leslie
Stahl uh by dint of where I was living
at the time they were doing a feature on
it and uh she was trying real hard to uh
get me this is like 91 or two trying to
get me to be really angry at Bill
Clinton even though I wasn't and didn't
live in America so why would I be
um and like stop the tape at some point
to like like coach me remember like
you're angry at Bill Clinton okay gonna
do a good 60 Minutes you know all right
I'll do whatever they tell me I'm gonna
do
um and they so start the role and she
goes what do you think about uh Clinton
I'm like you know that George Clinton
you know I just enough of him then and I
rammed it for about five minutes while
their face went totally blank and I I
have never been prouder to be as stupid
as I am did you make the little slap
bass motion
it was pretty slap at the base time
um sadly uh we're going to extend the
conversation via our uh listener email
of the week here in a moment but first a
reminder that this episode is brought to
you by betterhelp friends remember what
it was like to feel awesome it's kind of
hard for some of us to imagine that
during these dark days of January living
in lousy cold cities and fending off the
post covet doldrums but once upon a time
we would Skip and sometimes even hum A
little it's time to ask what's keeping
you from getting back in touch with your
inner happy-go-lucky person how do you
get to your good place for millions of
people therapy can help remove obstacles
and build new Pathways toward getting to
your very best self that's where better
help the world's largest therapy service
comes in better help is matched three
million people with an m with
professionally licensed invented
therapists it's an affordable service
100 online and super flexible if you
don't like your first match swap mount
for another until you find the right fit
and listeners who act right now can get
10 off their first month just go to
betterhelp.com Roundtable fill out a
brief questionnaire and find a quicker
path to your better self that's better
help like Peter Pan go there today
you'll be glad you did all right
reminder to send your brief
email queries to reason at
roundtable.com right no that's not right
Roundtable at reason.com what am I doing
uh this one in Abridged form comes from
Jim meluan and I hope I'm massacring his
name who writes
I have long held what I consider to be a
Libertarian position on College
admissions and affirmative action that
private colleges ought to be able to
control their own admissions policies
and that those who don't like these
policies can seek admission elsewhere I
am somewhat surprised that I do not find
any Libertarians making this argument
seems to me that if the Supreme Court
makes a determination that affirmative
action is illegal as well as other types
of arguably discriminatory admissions
policies such as preferences for alumni
and attempts to achieve Geographic
diversity in the student body then we
are in for a tsunami of lawsuits in
which every damn College applicant of
the country was turned down by her top
college pick will argue that she was a
victim of discrimination where does it
end so what does the panel think by what
logic are the details of private college
admissions policies a matter for the
courts how does the Constitution say
that the courts need to make these
decisions uh and again where will it all
end uh Nick is there a meaningful
distinction here that Libertarians ought
to be policing between private and
public admissions policies uh you know
there is uh you know theoretically but
legally under current uh you know under
current court rulings there is not um
and so Harvard and the University of
North Carolina Chapel Hill which are
part of the Supreme Court case which has
been heard and will be you know the the
ruling will be revealed later uh this
spring about
um uh discrimination against Asian
Americans uh there's effectively no
difference between being a public and a
private university if you take Federal
money uh in any way shape or form you're
covered by uh Federal
anti-discrimination practice so just as
As a matter of legal reality there's not
a case I think Jim Malone uh raises a
lot of interesting questions there I am
a little bit disheartened and sad at his
need to get Wesleyan in there I'm
surprised that he didn't mention that uh
lin-manuel Miranda and I went there
because that usually is the other reason
why people bring up Wesleyan
and we have friends and co-workers who
went there as well that we won't
embarrass by naming them but
um you know a lot of what's going on
with the anger here I think is Harvard
in particular is doing an incredible job
of gaslighting Asian Americans because
part of it you know part of that case
which I followed a lot we did a recent
live stream Zach wise Mueller and I had
reason with David Bernstein the George
Mason law professor and volat conspiracy
blogger and Kenny Zhu of colorus United
and they both were you know talking a
lot about how Harvard is lying about how
they are processing Asian American
applications and if they were a little
bit more honest about that it wouldn't
take the sting of rejection out but it
would change the conversation and it
turns out that you know the way that
Harvard and this has gotten a fair
amount of press and it's worth thinking
about is that way they they
um uh d uh emphasize or or you know like
downgrade Asian applicants which is
mostly Chinese uh students by the way
and some uh South Asian Indians
um but is that they say they have bad
personalities that wouldn't you know
that are they're they're you know
they're deficient and what's fascinating
is that what the courts uh you know the
the discovery process and the court case
has shown so far is that the alumni
interviewers who talk to these Asian
American applicants are like you know
what these people are really good like
they're as good as white students or
maybe even a little bit better and then
somewhere in the admissions office that
gets changed into a demerit and that's
why Asian Americans who are all are over
represented from the general population
of America at Harvard but they're not in
at the the same numbers that you would
think their test scores class rankings
extracurriculars Etc would would point
out but it's the lying about stuff and
this reminds me of the way that higher
the foundation for individual rights and
expression formerly the foundation for
individual rights and education
talked about private universities that
don't follow the First Amendment because
on that grounds they don't have to be as
as kind of robust as public universities
you know people like Alan Kors and Greg
licanov say you know part of the problem
is that these schools are lying to
students when they say you're coming
here and you're going to be able to have
a robust you know No Holds Barred
intellectual experience because they
don't do that so in a way the legal
issues aside what's going on here
particularly with the Harvard case UNC
is a little bit different you know is
that they're lying about how they are
saying well you know what Asian
Americans really aren't that interesting
and that should be deeply offensive I
think to all Americans Catherine you
went to non-harvard are you cheering on
this Supreme Court case and do you think
that that like Nick that there isn't
that much of a meaningful legal
distinction that we should be thinking
about
I mean I think that there is what this
case and what this General kind of
controversy has forced people to
confront is that you I think many many
people share the natural intuition that
schools should be able to put their
thumbs on the scale in the favor of
certain student groups but only
the ones sort of semi-arbitrarily that
Society is comfortable with or that
we've always done and the thing that
Nick just described uh with Native with
um Asian Americans is a very very close
parallel to the way that ivy league
institutions treated Jews a century ago
they basically crafted their admissions
policies in order to make Jewish
applicants
score lower this is the source of a lot
of the geographic diversity requirements
which are our question were actually
noted in the longer version of his
question
um you know if you have to admit some
kids from Wisconsin you know they don't
got a lot of Jews out there problem
solved and so
um this is
um this isn't going to go away
regardless of how the Supreme Court
rules on this case schools are still
profoundly deeply motivated to racially
select their student bodies and they're
going to keep doing that and that I
think is the thing that's that's under
appreciated here they're just going to
figure out another back door through
which to do this
um but but Nick is right it's it's you
know actually kind of shocking how these
schools are are leaning into negative
racial stereotypes about Asian Americans
in the service of this other this other
goal of kind of balancing schools I
think that private institutions should
be allowed to discriminate based on race
that's why Libertarians don't talk about
this because that sentence freaks people
out
um it freaks me out I don't even like to
say it but I think that
um you can't really solve this problem
without confronting the deepest
underlying question which is should it
be legal
to discriminate based on race not should
it be good I think it's not good but
should it be legal um and we have
separate jurisprudence right now for
school admissions and say
um you know
being able to book a room at a hotel but
it's still the same underlying question
it makes people nervous it should
because we have done this so badly in
the past in this country but we are
still doing it badly in school
admissions and um and I I hope that the
court sides with the um
with the folks who are pointing out the
real injustices in in these cases Peter
does it make you nervous at all in this
bit of a curveball
um the kind of polarization of race
related policies we are seeing uh exist
and being championed by
um in different parts of the country and
here's what I mean by that the Supreme
Court I think is probably going to I'm
looking at that closely but probably
going to strike down affirmative action
in this case a lot of people are going
to be really really mad about that
um and meanwhile in San Francisco uh I
think this week or recently a board that
was appointed to look into the
possibility of reparations is like yeah
we should give five million dollars uh
per black person here or some kind of
like you know 250 years worth of rent
relief I mean these things are couldn't
be more opposed
um are you worried about the way that
those Visions clash and even the way
that people talk about it clash with one
another in a way that seems kind of
income compatible
sure I'm worried you know just in
general but for some specific practical
reasons uh here which one of which is
that it's not at all obvious that um the
sort of uh the D let's the the
left-leaning Dei approach to the world
actually makes the world a uh someplace
that is better for the minorities for
the minority groups that the Dei folks
want to like improve life for um and so
there's a great uh piece just uh in the
New York Times today by a recent
contributor and sub stack writer Jesse
single uh who basically just outlines
the evidence that diversity trainings
almost certainly don't help in corporate
settings and also uh may it may in fact
make race relations worse in corporate
settings by highlighting uh by
highlighting racial differences or sort
of I shouldn't even say by highlighting
racial differences by emphasizing yes
the idea that there are that there are
of racial disparities it might it
creates resentments amongst amongst
white people it's sort of over overplays
the idea that sort of you know that
there's a
um that there are victim classes and
that there are sort of uh aggressor
classes and that like that that produces
a psychological effect that actually
deepens those divides in ways that are
at best not productive and at worst
counterproductive and I think that the
the a lot of our conversation around
race in America in 2023 looks a lot like
that where you've got folks who are
trying to emphasize
um racial difference as like a as
something that like oh you is basically
something that you can judge a group by
as that there's a that their immutable
group characteristics rather than the
idea that we should be judging
individuals as individuals I I guess I
also just slightly one of what a offer a
little bit of a tweak to Nick's uh
argument that there's no meaningful
legal distinction between the two cases
here so the Supreme Court is hearing two
different cases about affirmative action
one of which involves the University of
North Carolina which is just a public
university and as a public university as
a as a government institution
effectively it must comply with the
Constitution's equal protection clause
and that isn't a further requirement
that Harvard and other sort of nominally
private institutions don't have to
comply with and then when it comes to
Harvard they just have to comply with a
federal statute that says that if they
receive private excuse me if they
receive government money Federal money
then they have to comply with a sort of
uh with something they can't
discriminate um in their Admissions and
I don't think it's actually crazy for
the federal government to say that if
we're going to give your institution
money and in Harvard's case it's quite a
bit so just a quick Googling I can see
that in uh 2019 Harvard appears to have
taken 560 million so a half a billion
dollars just in research funding much of
which pays for staff salaries right so
this is going directly to instruction
and to you know uh to to employer to to
people who are employed by Harvard
they're taking half a billion dollars in
federal money and the there's some
strings attached one of which is you
can't discriminate now the Supreme Court
precedent has said uh in the past oh
actually you can consider race as part
of a contextual holistic sort of view of
the diversity right which is a good unto
itself but that's the question here is
whether Harvard is actually meaningfully
private in the sense uh that you know
Libertarians talking about private
institutions want to talk about and
there are colleges not very many but
there are colleges that do not take
Federal money and
um and it seems like Harvard could
decide oh we're just not going to take
the federal money and then we'll do
whatever we want and we would be and we
might be free of some of those
limitations and that's not on the table
because Harvard isn't going to give up
half a billion dollars in research
funding alone
yeah and if I may uh as David Bernstein
explain those distinctions ultimately
don't really matter in this in these two
cases but uh the question is is using
race a determining Factor you know like
is it the thing and the I actually
suspect that the federal uh that the
Supreme Court is going to basically
maintain the status quo and say that
these are not the determining factors uh
you know front and center in a way that
goes against existing precedent there's
a couple of cases that were settled
having to do with the University of
Texas and University of Michigan but
State schools uh that kind of set up the
current uh process would go to the
larger questions and there are not many
members of the Court who are left over
from those siblings
no I know well I'm I'm making a uh you
know a prediction here uh but the uh the
other thing that what you know if to
kind of draw a theme from earlier uh
talking about K-12 education if we want
to talk about transparency the fact is
that both public and private
universities use affirmative action all
of the time in various different ways to
kind of sculpt an incoming class that
they think best represents what they
supposedly are about
um and you know uh the number of women
who are attending college now who are
undergraduates is approaching 60 percent
and there's a ton of schools in the
country public as well as private that
are using affirmative action to keep men
in the mix because once you you know it
uh typically the way admissions officers
talk about this is that at the very
elite schools uh there's a ton you know
of male candidates who you know who
would come in if it's straight Merit
they bring in women you know who do fine
Etc but then at second tier institutions
you know it's actually women are much
more likely to be represented but girls
and boys don't want to go to schools
that have more than about 55 60 percent
one sex
um and so I know at one of the
universities Miami University which is a
public school in Ohio that my ex-wife
used to teach at they were openly
admitting Dumber on average Dumber male
students in order to keep the student
body kind of uh you know near 50 50. and
they were doing that because otherwise
boys and girls would stop coming
um you know there are athletic
scholarships which have absofucking
lutely nothing to do with higher
education music blah blah blah and I do
think one of a larger question here
which is not maybe not particularly
libertarian is if we had a wider
discussion of like what is you know what
is Merit what is a good uh you know
what's a good college freshman look like
and things like that we'd we we'd have a
more interesting conversation about
education politics
it's nope uh let's go to our end of
podcast what we have been consuming in
the cultural Arena uh Catherine why do
you lead us off
I started watching the latest Adams
Family reboot Wednesday and I am
enjoying it a lot the first episode in
particular really has like a Lanny
Freelander ghost writing credit on it
and by that I mean reasons founder Lanny
friedlander who in the first issue of
our magazine really leans into the
actually schools our prisons
Vibes in his writing
um Wednesday agrees she's been shipped
off to Nevermore Academy after uh
getting expelled from her previous
school for putting piranhas into the
pool to attack the water polo team and
she
just refer it's like the first five
minutes
um but it's um
it's she refers repeatedly to these
educational institutions as you know
prisons holding cells you know all kinds
of things and
um fair enough girl school is prison a
little bit and uh so if you're if you're
in the mood for uh what so far seems to
be quite a Charming series I love me I
will consume all Adam's Family content
um and so I was an easy sell for this
one
um there is apparently some dancing in
later episodes which became uh like a
whole viral thing
um so uh so yeah it's uh I wouldn't say
like I have a giant libertarian takeaway
but is school prison does seem to be a a
theme of this entire podcast so I will
recommend to those who made it to the
end of this podcast Wednesday are you uh
holding up for Pugsley I don't even know
what that means you don't even have any
idea what that means uh can I point out
on the equation of schools and prisons
RC Hoyles the legendary libertarian uh
editor-in-chief and and or publisher of
the Orange County Register the only
newspaper on the west coast major daily
to editorials
Turning Japanese Americans during World
War II once said you know the difference
between whorehouses and Public Schools
is that nobody's forced to attend
whorehouses
uh which is kind of great
um
I think there's some other differences
speaking of which Jesse Walker's uh
incredible feature on the history of
groomer politics is out so do without
what you want I'm sure Chris Ruffo is
doing plenty with that as we speak uh
Nick what did you consume
I uh consumed uh Helen Lewis the uh
British uh journalist uh new BBC podcast
series the new gurus uh which I highly
recommend it is uh like a seven or eight
part series their half hour episodes
about uh people uh who are like you know
people like pickup artists uh people
like uh end of worlders uh people who
drink their own urine for health and
profit
um and what's great about this series is
that Lewis actually goes and talks to
various people
um that she's are you know arguing with
she is like another British journalist
and podcaster John Ronson just very very
good at actually talking with the people
that she's interested in analyzing and
she does it in good faith ways she often
is Caustic and critical of them but is
open and fair and whatnot uh the most
interesting thing about this uh program
I think is the first episode which is
titled the birth of the new Guru and she
talks about Steve Jobs of apple as kind
of the model Forest a new Guru a new
leader who is enhanced by or made
possible by digital technology
particularly online uh you know the the
miracle of cheap online distribution and
marketing um I highly recommend it it is
a critical take she's sometimes wrong
about her topics the way that she talks
about Bitcoin gurus uh strikes me as you
know overly Arch and whatnot but there's
also a great episode about the women
behind the uh the dinners where you pay
five thousand dollars for white women to
go and eat and be lectured at by a black
woman in an Asian uh Indian American
woman about why you are racist and
whatnot it's great stuff the new gurus
by Helen Lewis Peter
I watched Megan the new surprise hit
horror movie about a killer AI doll it's
a it's a catalog of modern fears about
technology and modern parenting and your
Alexa devices and you know creepy-eyed
Murder dolls
um it's not a great movie but it's
actually a pretty effective one it
borrows uh pretty smartly from a bunch
of uh influences not just obvious stuff
like the great classic Chucky franchise
but Robocop and Terminator and does
anybody else here remember Teddy Ruxpin
right like my buddy my buddy oh my God I
had black and then there was like a a
girl one of the eyes would always break
and then it was like lazy lazy eye
automated automated this movie is
basically like one you know what we we
call those challenged eyes now no lazy
eyes come on this movie is basically
what if Teddy Ruxpin were a full-size
American doll with a Siri inside her and
maybe also chat GPT
plus murder
and it's it's pretty good for a movie
where that's the concept
um and it also it also kind of
interestingly makes the case for the
theatrical experience in a way that I
hadn't quite thought about before not so
much because it Demands a big screen and
a top-tier sound system this is not like
a big budget Avatar level Extravaganza
but it plays to the crowd really well I
saw this at a packed house on a Sunday
afternoon at the local Alamo Drafthouse
and this sort of knowing pretty goofy
high camp shocker is it's just a lot
more fun in a room with a whole bunch of
other people
I watched a theater production kind of a
play with music called King Gilgamesh
and the man of the wild uh on Saturday
and it's fantastic and it's only on for
four more days so if anyone is listening
to this and they've been sold out but
they have walk-up traffic that uh uh can
uh accommodate people to New York City
at the la mama uh theater it's part of
the experimental theater Festival
um it's a story it's a bromance frankly
um uh uh true to life of romance about
uh an Iraqi Refugee in Toronto uh named
Ahmed Monica and a American living in
Toronto who's kind of a marginal actor
uh named Jesse lavacom who have a chance
meeting at a cafe on an important day
for both of them and
um they end up spending uh uh a long and
intense evening and then kind of go
their separate ways but as part of that
initial encounter the Iraqi references
Gilgamesh which is the oldest uh epic
tale uh in Humanity's history as far as
we know
um and just he's like what's that and
then he maybe Google some of it on the
on the turlot and then they start
talking about it and the uh the thing of
the play is that it goes back and forth
between their encounter that night and a
little bit later and also the story of
Gilgamesh and his uh trusted buddy uh
who has uh some kind of name like in
Gita
um uh who is a beast
a lot of foreign words it's Canadian
Matt they speak a different language and
so they play Gilgamesh and ingidu
um who is a beast to Gilgamesh tries to
uh tames with a prostitute to make him a
sort of human and they conquer various
lands and attack the gods and but then
in gido suffers Misfortune then
Gilgamesh it toggles back and forth in a
really a great uh way
um and it's a funny
uh case of a funny meta story of the of
the piece itself
um which is uh it's directed by uh uh a
guy now named Seth Buckley
um and they had worked on it in Canada
and it's kind of the true story of these
two guys having forging an unlikely uh
friendship and also musical partnership
um and along the way covet happened and
it basically sort of incubated for four
years and over that time the band that
was sort of formed to
um tell this story became a huge local
hit during like World music and stuff
and Ahmed Monica
um went from being kind of an obscure uh
Refugee figure who's kind of big back
home in Iraq and he's and he's Refugee
for a pretty interesting reason
um he's now become kind of a celebrity
so it's very interesting uh they're
gonna take the production back to
Toronto and it's going to tour a little
bit and you can also find their music
but uh just a really great small good uh
play with good music King Gilgamesh and
the man of the wild the la mama theater
is that all is it all uh Gordon
Lightfoot songs not even one what's the
music channel uh not even one um it's
all uh in fact it's songs in uh whatever
devil tongue they speak in Iraq uh for
the most part
um and uh and it's great
um so uh go check it out if you can and
just follow those people I think they're
gonna be throwing off interesting
culture going forward um that's all the
culture interesting otherwise we have
time for here the reason Round Table
podcast uh if you like um our podcast
want to hear more of them
institutionally uh go to reason.com
podcast where you can find the recent
interview with nicolespie the Soho forum
debate series uh moderated by Gene
Epstein Stein
um I never can figure that out who's got
a rule of thumb about that by the way
that's I know but like is there like a
memetic is there no matter what you no
matter what you say it's anti-static
that helps uh thank you for that um and
as Bruce Springsteen nick uh is there
any live Speakeasy event that you are
taking part in in New York City that you
would like to advertise to our dear
listeners at this moment oh
well thank you so much Matt Welch on uh
Monday February 6th cat Rosenfield the
uh novelist uh whose book Catherine
whose latest book uh you must remember
this Catherine raved about just a week
or so ago uh and it was also a great
essayist for reason and for unheard uh
that website is going to be talking
about her novel about cancel culture
about uh sirens in the back background
and fights over people like Taylor Swift
Beyonce and lizzo uh censoring
themselves to avoid woke sanctions and
censure as well as uh big online fights
over whether or not liking big butts is
a form of cultural appropriation which
should not stand
um so that's Monday February 6th the
next reason Speakeasy in Midtown
Manhattan go to reason.com events to get
details tickets are 10 bucks beer wine
soda food and uh really great
conversation thank fantastic and if you
like what we do as an institution please
think about giving a tax deductible
donation go to reason.com donate all
right we'll catch you next Monday thank
you and good night
[Music]